[inaudible] [inaudible]
oh well,
welcome everyone.
I'm assuming that applause was not for me.
My name is Bill Flanagan and I'm the dean of law here at Queen's University and
I am pleased to welcome all of you here today for the inaugural liberty lecture,
generously sponsored by Greg [inaudible] law 80 a long time and very generous
supporter of the law school and Greg is here today and I just want to corrupt
the join me in thanking Greg for sponsoring this
[inaudible] [inaudible].
The Liberty Lecture is intended to explore the meaning of liberty in our
contemporary society,
a subject of rich interest to philosophers,
political scientists,
and legal scholars.
Just to name a few.
And today's liberty lecture is moderated by Professor Bruce Party to my right of
the Faculty of Law and experts in a variety of areas,
including environmental law,
environmental law and governance,
ecosystem management,
climate change,
water law,
and university governance.
Our guest today is Dr. Jordan Peterson,
a professor of psychology at the University of Toronto,
and a clinical psychologist.
His many publications include his recently published book,
12 rules for life,
an antidote to chaos and his research spans a number of topics including the
psychology of religion and the modern understanding of creativity and
personality.
I know that today's lecture has generated a great deal of interest as is evident
from the packed hall here today.
It's also generated a certain amount of heat.
The proposed topic,
the rising tide of compelled speech in Canada is for many a controversial one
and I know that many of you in the audience will hold widely divergent views.
I fully support your opportunity to be heard and should you wish challenge the
speakers to defend their positions.
I know that today's speakers likewise share this conviction and we'll welcome
your comments and questions as might be appropriate for a lecture series named
after liberty.
I believe it is also important for me to affirm at the outset that the core
values of the Faculty of law end of Queens University include academic freedom
and respectful dialogue among those with differing views.
This includes providing our speakers with the opportunity to be heard and
providing all of you with the opportunity to respond in a respectful
environment,
free from any harassment or any attempts to shut down the conversation.
So it is in this spirit of free and respectful academic exchange that I'm
pleased to launch or this new lecture series.
Welcome again and welcome to our guest and I look forward to our discussion.
Thank you.
[inaudible].
Okay,
thank you bill.
Welcome and thank you for coming.
I would like to underline what bill said,
which is that this event would not have happened without the initiative in
support of Greg kids asking you.
So Greg,
thank you very much
[inaudible]
as well.
Before we start,
I would like to thank some people from the Faculty of Law,
Diane Butler at him,
Blake Galippo and Christina Julian for their help in putting this together.
I would also like to acknowledge the support,
help and generous assistance of several people around the university.
Uh,
Lisa plater and event services,
David Patterson and the campus security office.
Uh,
you have been professional,
helpful,
straightforward and I thank you very much for making this possible.
I would also like to return to being Flanagan's observation about the importance
of this moment and to acknowledge the role that both being Flanigan and
principal wolf have played in enhancing the reputation of this university in
terms of its commitment to academic freedom and academic debate.
They have
reflected an unflinching commitment to those ideas.
As Principal Wolf said on his blog,
informed respectful debate is central to academia.
And Gentlemen,
I salute your academic statesmanship.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
so
we're going to proceed as follows.
A the first thing I would like to say is that in the hall behind you afterwards,
there will be some of Jordan's books on sale.
12.
Um,
what,
what's the title again?
12 rules for like 12,
12 rules for like wanting to get the 12 what it was,
right?
It's not,
that's not 12 steps.
It's 12 rules.
Right?
Um,
we are going to proceed as follows.
Jordan and I are going to have a conversation for half an hour,
maybe 40 minutes and then we are going to throw the floor open to questions.
We'll describe what kinds of questions that you should ask later on when we get
to that stage,
but our topic is the rising tide of compelled speech in Canada.
I am going to take just a couple of minutes to give us some context and set it
up and then I'll ask Jordan to tell us what he thinks.
You may have seen the CBC production of the tutors.
The story of King Henry the eighth
in one episode,
the king has condemned Thomas Moore to death
for refusing to say that the king is the head of the Church of England
more isn't his cell awaiting execution.
A friend comes to him to plead with him to say what it is the king wants to
hear.
Morris says he cannot do that for he does not believe it to be true.
Yeah.
In exasperate
the friends says,
you don't have to believe it.
You just have to say it.
When your brain makes that kind of calculation,
you know you are under the thumb of a tyrant
and Thomas Moore lost his head.
The tide of compelled speech in Canada is rising.
The Law Society of Ontario has introduced a new policy that requires each lawyer
to develop a statement of Principles which endorses and acknowledges an
obligation to promote certain values.
The Ontario Human Rights Commission says that under the Human Rights Code,
failing to address somebody by their preferred Pronoun will constitute
discrimination for which you may be investigated and prosecuted.
The Elementary Teachers,
Federation of Ontario has introduced new curriculum
to require teachers to teach elementary students about white privilege
and the Federal Summer Jay Grants Program requires applicants to attest to the
values,
but the government believes it.
Okay.
They don't have to believe it.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that's pure narcissism at work.
By the way,
[inaudible]
you do to hijack hijacking event like this that other people put time and effort
into and to use the civility of the crowd and the civility of the organizers as
an excuse to blatantly yellow.
You're ill informed opinions is no way to conduct a civil dialogue.
It's absolutely appalling.
The people who do that,
she'd be embarrassed.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I would also say that as students and his faculty members,
you shouldn't put up with it.
There's no way that you should allow people who are doing this to hijack your
educational opportunities and to bend and twist the functions,
the structures of the university.
It's not a good thing.
Not In any way at all.
He would say that was a very disgraceful display fundamentally.
So let's,
let's stick with it.
Why,
why do you think people are afraid of free speech?
Well,
you know,
people develop an ideological view of the world because they don't want to think
through things in real detail and they're aided and embedded in that endeavor by
their pathological professors who were feeding them.
Uh,
what would I say over simplified?
An oversimplified radical view of the world in my estimation,
is fundamentally based in,
in resentment.
Not that there's no reason for say,
a left wing view of the world and we can get to that later.
It's,
it's easy virtue.
You know,
you can stand up in front of 900 people with your black card and your and your
screeching and you can,
you can declaim to the entire audience,
your fundamental moral superiority.
You can tell everyone at,
at once that they're all beneath you and you're standing for the right thing.
And absolutely none of that is earned.
You know,
like,
what the hell?
What the hell was that?
There's no seriously man.
There's just,
it's just complete misbehavior.
It's embarrassing.
And the fact that the people who do that don't have enough sense to go hide
their head in shame just tells you how badly socialized they are and how
terribly educated they are.
And the thing is,
the thing that's so awful is that there are professors and educators who promote
that.
They say,
well,
that's how you change the world.
It's like it is how you change the world,
but it's certainly not how you make it better.
You make it worse.
Clearly,
you know,
there's no comfort and out and there's nothing about it,
this impressive.
It's no,
it's no better in some sense than a two year old having a tantrum on the floor.
It's a,
it shows as far as I'm concerned,
it approximate the same level of psychosocial development.
So when the fact that that this is happening continually,
universities is,
it's,
it truly makes me embarrassed to be associated with the university.
And now I say that with great displeasure because you know,
I've been working for great universities for a very long time and the university
is an absolutely remarkable institution.
You know,
it's survived for a thousand years and,
and to see it,
to see it brought down by,
by people whose behavior would be out of place at a four year old's birthday
party is,
is something something Bizible to behold.
So,
so what about the actions of government now because it has government after all
that is the source of this compelled speech as law as well as other ways in
which they seek to restrict speech.
But the compelled speech is the most egregious form of violation of how well
tell us about that.
Well,
I've been trying,
I've been trying to sort this out because you know,
if you're a clinician,
I would say one of the problems you always have when you're dealing with
behavior that's gone astray is to understand at what level of analysis you
should address it.
You know,
is it a theological problem?
Is it a philosophical problem?
Is it a psychological problem?
Is it social?
Is it economic?
These are very complicated questions.
Is it a trivial issue?
Is it an issue of rights?
Is it,
is it something else?
The people who put in the bill see 16 for example,
and its associated legislation make the claim that it's,
it's a legislative womb that's facilitated by nothing but compassion and desire
to expand the domain of,
of,
of let's say,
of rights and freedoms.
And you know,
there's nothing wrong in principle with expanding the domain of rights and
freedoms,
except of course for every right and for every freedom there's an attendant
responsibility and obligation.
So you have to keep that in mind.
When I looked at bill [inaudible] 16 and the legislation that surrounded it,
especially that was written by the Ontario Human Rights Commission,
the policies that surrounded it and also the policies that gave rise to the
social justice tribunals named social justice tribunals.
Appallingly enough that that that gave rise to those tribunals in Ontario.
The things I read just made my hair stand on end.
You know,
the social justice tribunals have the right to place themselves outside of
legal,
out of outside of jurors prudential precedence.
It's like,
what the hell is that?
It's really what you're going to make the case.
The only way I think that you could justify doing that is it if you torture
yourself into the ideological proposition that English common law is somehow an
oppressive branch of the patriarchy,
and because of that you have every right and even obligation to place yourself
outside of its structure of precedent.
But we don't want to.
Police are so outside of the structure of precedent of English common law.
I can tell you that it's,
it's one of the supreme achievements of the human race.
It's,
it's produced societies that are as free and as productive as any societies have
ever been anywhere on the planet and certainly are now and to dare to state that
you would place yourself outside of that precedent.
That's the sort of thing that made my hair stand on end.
And there were other elements of the policies that were equally reprehensible,
not least,
their complete incoherence of formulation.
You,
I couldn't understand some of it,
like I don't understand,
for example,
with regards to the gender,
uh,
propositions,
how it can be that you can be anywhere on the gender spectrum,
which by the way,
it's not a spectrum technically and it actually matters which words you use.
If you're writing law,
you can be anywhere or nowhere on that spectrum.
Like I don't know what that means and I don't believe that the people who wrote
it,
no,
what it means either and you don't write things that you don't understand into
the damn law.
You don't do that because the law unfolds in society and it tangles people up as
it unfolds.
And it's no joke when that happens.
So you'll be very,
very careful when you're writing law and you certainly don't want to write law
to push forward your ideological commitments,
especially in the face of precedent because precedent is what keeps law from
degenerating into audiology essentially.
So and so.
And so,
you know,
Tamtam answer your question,
more,
more fundamentally,
I don't believe that this argument has ever been about the rights of transgender
people.
I think that it's an attempt by the radical left ideologues to push their
ideological agenda forward using,
using,
they're using attempts to manipulate the linguistic domain.
And I'm not willing to seat the loot linguistic domain because I don't think
there are any more,
anything more important than the words that you use.
And then when the government says we,
you should start using these words.
You should start thinking hard about your damn government because your words are
no different than your thoughts and your thoughts.
Orient Yourself,
your thoughts orient you in the world.
And if someone who's going to tell you what it is that you have to think,
then they're going to disorient you in the world.
And I wouldn't recommend that because there's lots of terrible things that can
happen to you.
And if you're disoriented,
you're going to run into a very large number of them.
So that's how it looks to me.
So,
but,
but the
ideological context of this,
it seems like something has changed.
Yes.
Because if you think back decades earlier,
liberals were the champions of free speech.
Yes.
It was the conservatives at a certain moment in time,
who are the sensors,
you know,
they,
they sought to curb a blasphemy and obscenity,
sedition and so on.
And the,
and the Liberals said,
no,
free speech is the way we want to go.
And yet today that has flipped a,
if you,
if you look back to what left leaning officials and authorities and,
and,
and figures said,
lemme just give you one quote.
This is Samuel Gompers who is the founder of the American Federation of Labor in
1886 he said this,
he said,
the freedom of speech has been granted to the people in order that they may say
the things
which,
sorry.
Misquoted that have not been granted to the people in order that they may say
the things which please and which are based upon accepted thought.
But the right to say the things which displease the right to say the things
which may convey the new and yet unexpected thoughts.
The right to say things even though they do a wrong.
Now that is not a sentiment now carried on by the left and today what has
happened?
Well again I see that it's a consequence of continued agitation,
agitation by I would say a minority of of the left,
the radical left in particular.
And those are people who aren't Marxist Slash Neo Marxist in their fundamental
ideological orientation and have joined that in an unholy union with the worst
of French,
postmodernism and and they push it ideological certainty.
And the thing that,
the thing that's really distressing about that is that if you know anything
about the history of oppressed people,
let's say much as I hate to engage in that particular form of dialogue under the
current conditions,
it's pretty obvious that it's freedom of speech is freedom.
That's particularly important for people who don't have anything else.
Right?
It's if you're supporting freedom of speech are not supporting the status quo.
I mean,
just think about,
let's,
let's use the logic of the radical leftists and assume that society is a
tyrannical hierarchy and the people at the top have the upper hand in everything
including access to communication.
These people are not your friends.
No.
Mark my words.
Now it's the sounds of the barbarians pounding out the gate.
Right?
Yeah.
That's all.
I'll tell you again,
that use of in Kuwait,
what would you call it in Kuwait sensation is the best formulation of their
argument.
And there's not much difference between knocking on the doors and knocking on
you.
So keep that in mind.
It's not a music,
there's nothing to it,
there's nothing for it.
The thing that's also quite appalling is that there's no evidence whatsoever
that the people who are conducting these protests know what it is that they're
protesting against.
You know,
I was in,
alright,
alright.
I was in the midst of a discussion and attempting to make the case that it's
freedom of speech.
That's,
that is what people who have nothing still have,
right.
So if you look at the tyrannical structure of our society,
let's say the people at the top have access to means of communication.
Everyone knows that it's the people at the bottom who have the right to say what
they think,
however badly they say it,
that enables them to get a toe hold into the system and to,
and to make their suffering known.
That's what freedom of speech is for.
And so like what's the protest against that?
And I'll tell you,
you know the rowdy called Neo Marxists types.
They speak the language of power and that's what they're speaking right now.
And if you want to live in a world where everyone speaks the language of power,
then just let them do what they're doing and see what happens.
I wouldn't recommend it.
It's not a pretty rote.
And you're all in a position,
you're on a situation in your life now where you have to make decisions about
this sorts of things.
Like is this the sort of institution that you want this to be?
Nope.
One of the,
uh,
one of the
arguments against what you said about the pronouns Yup.
Was that,
well,
after all,
all you're being asked to do is to say something that is reasonable.
It's not unreasonable to address somebody by the pronouns that they prefer.
And yet,
if you think of any kind of speech which is prescribed,
imagine a statute that said people shall use the words hello and please and
thank you in their conversations.
That statute is untenable.
Yes.
Because it now required there's
people to use certain words in their conversations,
even if those words are reasonable themselves.
So that is not the question.
And it was not your case.
You are making that using a pronoun was unreasonable itself.
Do I have that correct?
Well,
yeah.
First of all,
there's a couple of things I'd like to say about that.
No,
I looked up the process by which the Ontario government formulated it's
legislation with regards to the pronouns and the consultation process that you
used and the consultation process was deeply flawed.
They contacted activists and say,
let's activists of the Trans Community.
Okay.
Well,
there's a couple of things I'd like to say about that.
The first is there is no trans community,
right?
Trans people are as diverse as any other group of people,
and to the idea that somehow because of one of their attributes,
they constitute a homogenous group is a,
well,
you'd think that that would be a false with dip,
the people who are concerned about treating groups of people adequately would be
loath to,
to put forward,
but even more importantly,
there's absolutely no evidence whatsoever that the activist types are actually
representatives of any of the communities that they hypothetically activate on
behalf of.
It's like they're not elected,
they're not appointed,
they don't pull,
they do this.
They say,
look,
here's a group.
It's a minority group and it's oppressed.
I'm a member of that group and therefore I stand for the group.
It's like,
actually,
no,
you don't.
You don't stand for your group.
You maybe stand for yourself.
You know,
I don't stand for men and I don't have to stand for white men.
I'm not,
I'm not entitled to speak on their behalf.
And so the idea that it's the trans community that wanted this is a completely
unsustainable idea.
It's certainly unproven.
I've had like 40 letters from trans people since I started to engage in this,
call it
chaotic battle.
The only one of them was mildly critical of what I was doing.
All the other ones,
there aren't that many trans people,
you know.
So to get 40 letters is actually quite a few.
I'm not saying that this is a scientific Paul,
but it's at least as scientific as the process by which the Ontario government
generated it's legislation and I'm not
okay
and I'm not generating legislation.
And what these people said to a person was,
I didn't ask to be the newest whipping boy for the radical postmodernists.
All it's done is made my life more difficult.
You know,
that basic letter would say,
well,
I'm transitioning from one gender to the other and it's very difficult and I'm
not sure that it's the right thing to do.
And this has made the process spectacularly more difficult on all fronts.
It's like these people don't speak for me.
And just because they say they do,
that doesn't mean they do.
And so the other thing that we seem to have swallowed as a society is this crazy
notion that,
well,
first of all,
that we should be portioned up into our different minority groups,
which I think is a return to tribalism,
an unbelievably dangerous,
I can't really think of anything more dangerous than that.
And then we've swallowed the idea that if you identify yourself as a member of a
minority group and then you bring forward a grievance,
you have to be treated as if you're a valid representative of that group.
It's like,
Whoa,
why in the world would we do that guilt?
I suppose maybe that's part of it or I think it's mostly guilt.
You don't want to stand up and say,
well,
you know who died and made you king so to speak.
You know?
And can we,
can we stay on that logic for a moment?
The the idea.
So this,
this compelled speech material seems to insist upon treating people not as
individuals,
but as members of groups do either blame them or to favor them as a member of a
group.
Like we take that logic and extended,
you know that the group identity thing becomes intersectionality where you're
not just blogging to one group,
but you're also abuse characteristics.
Spin that outbursts.
What,
what,
what is the logic of that?
Where does it lead us to know?
Okay,
so the first thing I would say to everyone in the room is,
I don't think,
and this is why I decided to do what I did right from the beginning,
you know,
is that I don't want to play the group identity game.
I don't want to construe the world in those terms and I'm not going to use
terminology that would require me to formulate my thoughts in that manner.
I think it's a terrible catastrophe to divide us all up into our tribal
entities.
Don't see anything positive about that at all.
So I just don't want to go there.
And then second,
I would say,
and maybe this is even more relevant,
you may or may not have heard about intersectionality,
but intersectionality is a new development on the radical left.
And I think it's actually,
if I wasn't so in tandem on serious this and these matters,
I would be constantly laughing about intersectionality.
And the reason for that is that it's the radical left has discovered its own
Achilles heel.
So look,
what's the problem with dividing us up into groups?
Well,
there's many.
And the descent into tribalism is not least among them,
but the next is that,
well,
it turns out that we don't fit into one group.
Any of us,
we fit into multiple groups.
And it's not obvious at all.
Which of those groups should take,
should be of paramount importance.
You know,
there's a racial group and an ethnic ethnic group,
and there's groups of intelligence and there's groups of temperament,
there's groups of attractiveness,
and there's groups of wealth and you can multiply them really indefinitely.
And I do mean indefinitely because you can categorize a finite number of
entities,
a virtually infinite number of ways.
And so the intersection lists discovered this.
They said,
well,
there's,
let's say there's Latinos and there's,
and there's Asians.
It's like,
okay,
well wait a minute.
There's male and female Latinos and there's male and female Asians.
So,
so do we treat,
is the division into two enough or do we need a division into four?
Well then,
then,
well then there's socioeconomic class of male and female,
Asians and male and female Latinos.
And,
and you can keep fractionating the groups and technically without,
and,
and you actually see this happening in real time,
so to speak,
as the,
uh,
acronym for the LGBT activists continues to expand really without end and see
what's at the bottom of intersectionality.
And this,
I suspect,
will be discovered eventually by the radical leftists if they get that far as
the,
you have to fractionate the groups right down to the individual.
And that's what Western culture discussed in articulated,
discovered in,
articulated over the last 5,000 years.
It's like,
oh,
right.
The group isn't the paramount division.
It's the individual.
Because unless you treat each person like an individual,
you're not taking all the intersections into account.
And so it's extraordinarily,
it's extraordinarily comedic.
But it also isn't as if it's treating everyone as they're an individual,
as if they're an individual,
is an instant solution that will bring us to utopia.
You know,
it's,
it's like Winston Churchill said of democracy,
right?
It's,
it's essentially the least terrible approach we have.
An life isn't the sort of problem that is amenable to an instantaneous utopian
solution,
but our best bet is to meet each other with the desire for peace and
productivity on this,
on the stage that enables individual interaction because then we meet soul,
the soul,
so to speak.
And we also meet in a domain that we bear responsibility for as individuals.
And that's also extremely important,
right?
You should be responsible for what you say.
You should have to suffer the consequences of what you say,
not least so that you learn.
And so the individual is paramount as far as I'm concerned.
I think that's the fundamental principle of Western civilization.
You know,
it's not only the west that has come across that discovery,
but I think we've done the best job so far of articulating it.
And so we don't want to lose that because the alternative isn't a multicultural
utopia.
The alternative is a descent into tribal barbarism.
And,
and there are people who would be just as happy if that happened.
But I would suggest that it's not a destiny that in a weak person would,
would,
would long for.
Yeah.
Do you feel like taking a few questions,
do you feel like taking some questions from the storage shirt?
All right,
so we're going to have questions and we'd like you to participate in this
conversation now.
Please do ask a question.
We welcome you up to say what you'd like.
If there is a preamble to the question that's fairly shorts then so be it.
But please do ask a question.
We're not actually in buddy speeches and we do primarily want to hear,
but Jordan has to say,
so feel free to line up at the two microphones.
We'll take one at a time.
Go ahead sir.
Uh,
so first of all,
thank you so much for being here.
I really enjoyed it.
Um,
[inaudible]
and a second,
I'm,
this ties into my question.
I just last week my free speech coalition at Bishop's University was officially
ratified and I would love to invite you to be our first guest speaker,
if that's at all possible.
Um,
oh,
thank you.
Um,
and my,
my question pertains to this,
um,
for Dr. Peterson,
what would you consider the most under discussed or,
um,
overlooked ideas and topics that you think should be discussed in the club?
Because I know we're looking for controversial ideas that we think are maybe not
as discussed as much as they should be.
Well,
that's,
uh,
that's a difficult question.
I would say that
it isn't obvious to me that on university campuses at the present time or in the
education system in general,
we've done a good job of taking stock of the advantages and disadvantages of our
current sociopolitical systems now.
And I think there's enough data so that we could start having intelligent
conversation.
So one thing I would recommend to you all if you're interested is a book I just
finished reading.
It's called the great leveler,
the great leveler by Walter Shy Dale.
And it's a discussion of inequality and it's a very intelligent book.
So one of,
so inequality,
as you may or may not know,
is rife throughout human societies,
right?
And that's the case in the present day.
And it's been the case historically,
but it's also the case in animal societies by every measure.
So inequality is the rule of life,
let's say.
And that doesn't mean it's not an ethical catastrophe.
I'm not saying that,
I'm just saying that the fact of inequality cannot be laid at the feet of the
west or of capitalism or,
or really have any human construction for that matter.
One of the things Shydel did was to investigate empirically the relationship
between inequality and the pole of government.
So because let's say if you,
if you surveyed a very large number of states,
you could determine whether this,
the governments were left wing or right wing and then you could,
you could do a compilation of inequality coefficients and you could find out if
left wing governments had any,
any ability to ameliorate inequality.
Just as an empirical question.
And the answer that Shydel generated was no,
there's no difference whatsoever in the inequality coefficients and left and
right wing states.
And what that points to is a much more fundamental problem.
And Shydel in his book also points out that the only known historical forces
that limit inequality or that produce inequality are war revolution and
pestilence.
It's doesn't look like it's easily under,
under human control.
And so,
you know,
the Marxists talked about inequality and the fact that capital tends to
accumulate in the hands of fewer and fewer people,
which is sort of true,
except that the people at the top tend to rotate lot more quickly than that.
Then the communists in the Marxist separate presumed,
but it doesn't look like that's a consequence of capitalism.
It looks like it's a much deeper process and capitalism at least,
well,
it's shoveling money and resources up to the top also does lift the bottom very,
very quickly.
You know,
and this is something we need to have a serious discussion about it in the
university.
So like one,
because we shouldn't be doing this,
we should be partying in the streets.
And here's one reason why do you know that the level of absolute poverty in the
world fell by 50% between the year 2000 and the year 2012 do you know that was
three years faster than the most optimistic UN projection considered.
It was the fastest decline in absolute poverty that the world has ever seen.
And like that's a big deal.
You know about,
there's hundreds of thousands of people a week right now that are being
connected to the power grid and almost everybody has access to high speed
computation.
And the,
the,
the struggling economies in Africa have for the last four years being the
fastest growing economies in the world.
You know,
there's almost no absolute privation left.
There aren't people starving except for political reasons.
We're at a point where obesity is the worst,
worst problem than starvation,
you know,
and,
and now I also think that a lot of that was purchased out,
the cost of the,
of the dreams and hopes of the working class in the west.
You know,
I think what we did some sense for about a 30 year period is sacrificed the
aspirations of the Western working class to alleviate poverty,
get India and China and in South East Asia.
And it looks like that might have been a really good deal,
although it was a little bit hard on the working class people and that has to be
taken into account,
but we're not having discussions of is sort universities.
It's like we're stuck in 1980 or maybe a 1960 we haven't updated our bottles.
We take into account the new and often extraordinarily positive realities and
we're tearing ourselves apart in the west with this identity,
politics,
idiocy.
At the same time,
the things are getting better and better,
faster and faster than they ever have by a huge margin in the history of
mankind.
So it's like,
it's time to wake up and throw off the depression of the Cold War and,
and,
and to look around and see what's what's available in front of us and what we
could accomplish that would be much better than Oh,
yes.
Yeah.
So
right.
Told that,
uh,
there are developments outside.
I'm sorry for the noise.
The,
uh,
we'll will,
they're doing the best they can.
Uh,
yes ma'am.
Was there a fetus in youth said that Europe had one was one of your highest
priorities is the pursuit of truth?
Could you just clarify what Ruth,
you mean when you're presented with a situation where you have to,
or you're being asked to refer to someone to their preferred pronouns,
and is it,
is it a truth they do see is that their truth is your truth
be the issue
isn't the request of the individual to be addressed in a certain matter.
It's the compulsion of that by law.
So at least issues get conflated constantly.
Look,
I've dealt with all sorts of people in my life,
a much broader range of people than most people ever encounter in the course of
their entire lives.
And I'm perfectly capable of deciding how to treat someone on a one to one
basis.
But when the demand for,
for terminology becomes part of the legal system,
I don't care what the rationale is.
It's not happening as far as I'm concerned.
And people say,
well,
we're pushing it forward because of compassion.
And maybe you could stop just being such a mean professor.
It's like,
why should I believe that?
You know what the hell you're doing with your compelling laws.
You're willing to,
you're willing to move past illegal wine in the sand that's been drawn for let's
say,
700 years.
You do not write compelled speech into the legislation all but we're doing it
with the best of intense.
Yeah.
No,
you're not.
So these issues have to be separate.
Look,
if this was about transgender rights,
it would have disappeared in September of 2016 it's not about transgender rights
and everyone knows it.
So this is not about transgender rights.
What these,
what these people are doing outside.
It's about something far deeper than that.
We ask the question this way.
Can we say,
don't
have the rights,
the liberty to decide how to present themselves.
You know how to be who they want to be,
what's aware.
You know,
what,
what gender to call themselves.
And the answer is yes.
Everybody has the liberty to do that.
What everybody else has liberty too.
And the liberty to do that doesn't mean they have the right to compel other
people to agree with it.
In other words,
liberty is not the right to demand that the world validate the choices that
you've made.
You have your choices,
you have the freedom to make the choices and everybody else has the freedom to
make their choices too and to approve or disapprove and they call you this or
like all your that.
In other words,
liberty is a two way street and everybody has it.
And the fact that you've made choices,
it doesn't mean everybody else doesn't have the same ability to make the same
choices
back.
Mike,
Please go ahead.
Hi.
Um,
that was loud.
I just want to thank you for being here.
I'm really big fan and um,
I have a bad habit of making or,
uh,
getting in arguments with a lot of radical leftists and I'm the most common
argument they present to me,
I generally is bills you 16 only covers the Ontario human rights code.
So those are protected areas under the Ontario Human Rights Code,
uh,
such as,
universities,
uh,
elementary schools,
et cetera.
I was just wondering,
um,
how you would combat this argument.
Seeing is their argument is generally,
um,
they're only dealing with vulnerable groups such as young students and um,
he's still got about enough.
It doesn't matter.
They say,
well it's,
it's restricted in scope.
Yeah.
It's not restricted enough.
Look,
here's a couple of facts.
Okay.
So when I first made my video is about bill [inaudible] 16,
one of the things that I suggested was that the act of making the video itself
could well have been illegal.
And of course people immediately accused me of fear mongering and perhaps with
reasons,
it's not always easy to understand the full intent of the new piece of
legislation surrounding policies.
But I can tell you one thing.
When the lawyers at the University of Toronto read through the new legislation
and the surrounding policies,
they also decided that what I was doing might've been transgressing the law.
And that's why they wrote me two letters telling me to stop.
Okay.
So that's number one.
Okay,
fact
number two,
two words,
Lindsay Shepherd.
Okay,
so
let's say for the argument that I'm a paranoid,
make a little maniac and that I'm a bigot and all of the other things that
people have decided that I might be okay.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
in my paranoid Megalomania,
I never envisioned a situation where a teaching assistant,
a 22 year old teaching assistant at a major Canadian university would be hold in
front of a quasi myo is inquisition and have to record it because she dared to
show five minutes of a video from a mainstream news program run by public
television funded by the government of Ontario.
So paranoid as I was,
let's say,
it isn't obvious that I was paranoid enough.
So,
and I don't see that.
I don't see how either of those examples can be disputed.
You know,
it wasn't like the University of Toronto wrote me two letters without thinking
about it.
They went and consulted their high powered lawyers and the lawyers reviewed the
policies and the legislation and they thought,
oh,
Dr. Peterson,
he might be contravening that legislation.
It's like,
it was a weird paradoxical gift to me that they sent out those two letters
telling me to stop because it was instant proof that what I was doing was,
um,
I wouldn't say right because God only knows about that.
But at least if my interpretation of the bill and its intent was correct,
so can we just make this observation that,
that,
that response to Jordan's critique of see 16,
the one that went,
oh,
he's overreacting.
Nobody's going to be punished or sent to jail for this
silly.
In this sense,
remember,
every single legal rule there is,
is a legal rule only because it is backed with the mum.
Monopolistic violence of the state.
They're ready.
[inaudible]
there's no such thing as a rural without punishment.
So if,
if for example,
there's a no parking sign,
what the practicing science says,
oh by the way,
please don't park here.
But there are no tickets.
Well people are going to park cause that's not really a rule.
So if you have a rule in the human rights code and if you breach it,
if that's discrimination,
well then true.
The first thing that happens to you is not going to be thrown in jail.
But there's a process,
a series of steps,
right?
The first one might be a mediation or an investigation and then there might be a
fine.
And then if you don't pay the fine,
then your wages might be garnished or you might be ordered to fix it.
But believe me,
if you refuse and refuse and refuse and refuse,
that order will become a court order.
And then if you don't obey the court order,
you'll be in contempt of court.
And then that will lead to arrest and imprisonment.
So every single rule in the human rights code
is effectively enforced with the most severe violence the state has,
even though it's not actually practiced most of the time.
Because most people obey
when we,
we also don't want to underestimate,
I don't know how many of you have had the pleasure of being dragged before a
board that investigates your behavior,
but I would tell you that even if you don't end up paying a fine or in jail,
there's nothing particularly pleasant about the process itself.
It's enough.
You know you wonder why people don't speak up and I can tell you one of the
reasons they don't speak up is because merely being dragged in front of a board
of inquiry,
innocent or guilty is enough to pretty much do you in for a whole year.
Like if you're a sensible person and you're concerned with propriety and you
want to maintain the stability of your life and your reputation is important to
you,
perhaps because of the stability of your family depends on it to be investigated
for such things as a punishment.
All of its own.
It's no,
it's no pleasant business and many of you will you're and stuff.
I would,
I would equate being investigated by a non punitive court,
let's say with these punishments that Bruce described quite far down the
distance.
I would equate that to having a,
a fairly serious disease in terms of its,
in terms of it's psychological and physical impact.
I would also say
no I won't,
I won't say it.
Let's go with the next project that's across the place.
Thank you.
First of all,
they can vote
as embarrassing as what's happening out there is easy university.
I think what it does when I could show how what we're doing here,
is it how we can,
those people are so thank you.
First of all,
[inaudible] of my questions,
your belief that it's extremely important.
Everything that we're doing to speak our mind speaking freely.
That's why we're here.
But in terms of practicality,
there's a lot of things that get,
are in the way of her license.
Students,
you know,
we have our prospective soap.
Um,
in terms of practicality,
what are kind of maybe your tips and your perspective on the steps that students
can take to kind of speak their mind while not sacrificing their future back?
Well,
I can tell you a couple of things that are very practical.
Don't break in your essence what you think the professor wants to hear.
There's absolutely no excuse whatsoever for doing that.
Now,
first of all,
most professors,
even those who have descended into a state of ideological possession,
let's say most
of them still have enough character to breed an essay that's well written.
So you're actually taking less of a risk than you would think by stating what
you have to stay.
But look,
if you start practicing when you were in University of mistakes,
you're rather low pandering to the audience,
let's say and say what you think will get you buy.
You're going to train yourself to do that.
And what that means is you're going to train yourself in the false suffocation
of your character and your character is the only thing you have to guide you
through life.
No people dream of riches.
And they dream of luxury and all of that.
But that's a thin defense against the harsh realities of the world.
You have your character.
And so what you do when you go to university is you learn to say what you think
is clearly as you can and to take the slings and arrows that come along with
that.
No,
I didn't.
An hitting manner,
right?
Because like what the hell do you know?
You know,
so you've got plenty to learn,
but you want to formulate your thoughts carefully.
You want to write what you think.
Well,
why?
Because when you're writing,
you're thinking,
you're laying out the arguments that you're going to use to structure your
existence in the world throughout your entire life.
And if you start to twist and bend those for expedient reasons,
you're going to warp your soul.
And I mean,
I could talk about that neurophysiologically if you want to,
you know,
you become what you practice,
you automate what you practice.
So if you automate expedient speech for the sake of short term gain,
then that's what you're going to produce.
You're going to produce expedient speech for short term gain.
Well God help you if you do that,
like there is nothing that you will possibly do in your entire life that will
serve you better than to get control of your voice in university.
I remember seeing you do that by reading,
right?
You read great people.
You do that by writing what you think.
You stay true to yourself while you write what you think and you take the risks
and you gain the benefits that go along with that.
You learn to stand up and speak and to listen carefully and that makes you a
negotiator of unparalleled power.
And if you're a negotiator of unparalleled power,
there's nothing in the world that won't open itself up to you.
So that's what you're doing in university.
And if you find professors who,
who reject that and there's fewer of them than you might think,
then it's your sacred obligation to stand up for yourself against that because
it's going to happen to you throughout your whole life.
And you might as well start practicing how to do it right now.
So that's how it looks to me.
Yeah.
There's an old saying that I write
[inaudible]
I write in order to know what I think.
And you'll note how compelled speech interferes in that process.
Yes.
So the idea that you have to write what professor wants is a form of compelled
speech.
It's like it.
I really do believe that this is a fundamental issue.
As a therapist,
say when I'm trying to help someone set their life straight,
I do my best not to compel their speech.
And the reason for that is quite clear.
It's like you have your destiny with all its attended triumphs and sufferings
and it's on your shoulders.
I don't want to tell you how to think.
I don't want to tell you how to think because I do not know how you should
think.
You have to figure that out for yourself and,
and then you have to bear the responsibility for that.
And you,
you were a terribly arrogant fool.
If you dare to tell someone else how it is that they should conduct themselves
through life.
Now.
I mean,
having said that,
while obviously I say,
well,
you should tell the truth or at least you shouldn't lie,
but that's not a dictate of,
of,
of actions so to speak.
It's a dictate of process.
It's like,
well,
you can't,
you shouldn't interfere with the mechanism that allows you to solve all the
problems that you will face in your life and you come to university maybe to
prepare for,
uh,
for a,
for a profession,
no,
and to set yourself up economically,
but to set yourself economic economically,
properly.
I don't care what your profession is going to be.
There is no one who is more powerful than someone who can communicate.
It doesn't matter what the field,
it doesn't matter if you're a plumber or a politician.
If you can formulate your thoughts clearly.
If you can conduct yourself honorably in your action and your speech,
if you're articulate and careful,
then the world opens itself up to you.
You have an unlimited horizon of possibility.
So thank you very much.
Yup.
[inaudible]
oh,
thank you both for coming with,
firstly,
I'd like to thank everyone in the room who is not devolved into the hysteria we
see outside.
They would prefer that we lost our sanity and that our society would fracture
into the nonsense we see.
So by sitting here,
being as patient as you are,
this is how we keep our academy.
This is how we keep our society.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
my question is a simple one.
Uh,
we see more and more of this new language I call of leftism,
intersectionality,
equity,
diversity,
inclusion,
and we see people from all political and philosophical straights adopting this
new vernacular.
Is this in any way dignifying that as a position,
is this dignifying the philosophical bases of these words?
Do people recognize that when they use these,
uh,
these words that they making that somehow a truth that we all ought to,
except I don't,
should we or should we not?
I don't think people,
you recognize that.
Again,
you know what I'd like reiterate with the reason I made those videos to begin
with was because I don't,
I was unwilling to see the linguistic territory as soon as you think it's
already happening to some degree.
So imagine that we just did define the sociopolitical landscape in terms of
identity politics,
which is happening very rapidly.
In fact,
we're compelled to do so.
Right?
So,
um,
well then,
then what happens is you get activity on the identity politics front on the left
and on the right the left says,
well,
the oppressed shall rise and take their rightful place.
And the right says,
yeah,
over my dead body and probably yours too.
So as soon as we played the identity politics game,
that's where we're at.
And we start playing it by accepting the terminology.
You know,
already I find myself stumbling when I used the word sex instead of gender.
And that's not good.
Like I have to consciously overcome a resistance to use the word sex instead of
gender because you know,
I'm actually quite an agreeable person and it actually pains me to,
to go against the crowd.
Let's say,
you know,
I'm not temperamentally suited for it precisely,
strangely enough.
And so I feel the compulsion to use this kind of language welling up inside of
me just to be,
to be nice,
I suppose,
you know,
but I know where identity politics leads.
It leads to the Ghoulag,
it leads to the concentration camps.
It leads to blood in the streets.
We don't need that here.
We're doing pretty well.
So we could leave it.
Hi,
Professor Peterson.
Uh,
I studied history for the duration of my degree and I think it's just a
sickeningly ironic that the people who are using their free speech,
one to take away your free speech and furthermore that they can't see the irony
of this situation of how tyrannical there being a,
my question is,
however,
um,
I've noticed from a lot of what you've talked about and I've been watching you
since your rise in 2060,
2016,
um,
and I know that you're a Christian and I don't want to divulge into that,
but I noticed a lot of the sort of North American Protestant work ethic in,
in,
uh,
in your lessons.
Like,
you know,
uh,
self redemption and to be your own person.
Like we've been talking about that last like hour and a half I suppose.
And um,
in a ever rising tide where people are,
or rather in the western world where it's becoming increasingly rather
decreasingly Christian and specifically,
yeah.
Decreasingly religious nuns specifically decreasingly Christian.
How can you,
what do you think is the best suggestion in order to be able to uphold those
such important values that have been across the world,
uh,
from American cultural influence since the end of the Second World War?
I apologize for the long question.
No,
no,
it's fine.
You know,
people have asked me repeatedly my religious views and I've answered them in a
variety of different ways,
but they say,
do you believe in God?
Let's say my response to that always is,
well,
I don't know what you mean when you ask me that question.
So I don't know how to answer it.
I don't know what you mean by belief,
but I can tell you something that I believe and I would say this is a way of
speaking symbolically.
I do believe so.
I was thinking the other day and week ago I was thinking about this I this
little fantasy that entered my mind.
I was thinking about Saint Joseph's oratorial in Montreal and Saint Joseph's
oratory.
It was a very large religious building.
It's one of the biggest cathedral light structures in the world,
and it's set on the hill and mount royal and it's set up where it can catch the
sun,
you know?
So it's an image of the heavenly city on the hill,
right?
It's an image of the structures that we strive to create.
That's what it is in independent of its specifically Christian or religious
function.
That's what it stands for symbolically.
Okay,
so it's the city on the hill.
It's,
it's what we're striving towards when we walk up hill in life.
Okay?
Now the way the,
the,
the oratory,
it was structured,
there's hundreds of steps leading to it up front.
And in the early part of the 20th century,
a lot of people who had physical disabilities came there and they struggled up
the step on their crutches and many of them left their crutches in the
oratorial.
You can see hundreds of them if you go there.
It's quite an interesting site.
And I was thinking about that and I was thinking about what that meant and this
is what it means.
It means that you know,
everyone has their disabilities,
let's say,
and I know that some people are far more terribly effected than other people.
I'm perfectly aware of that.
But the question is what do you do about that?
And what you do is you set yourself up on your damn crutches and you struggle up
the bloody hill.
That's what you do.
And you struggle up the hill towards the Kingdom of God.
That's what you do because the alternative is to descend into the abyss.
That's the alternative.
And then so to say,
well,
do you believe it's like I believe that you should struggle uphill towards the
city of God on your crutches.
That's what you should do.
That's the opposite of the descent into the abyss.
And so that's,
that's at the foundation of our civilization.
That idea.
Well,
argue with it.
If you will,
see if you can figure out why that's not an acceptable idea.
Maybe you should help someone's struggle up the hill.
Perhaps you should,
you know,
you can lend a hand to someone or you don't want to take the burden away from
them entirely because there's something noble about struggling up the Damn Hill,
right?
There's something that's adventure.
That's the call to proper being.
It's like,
well,
we don't need to forget this.
No,
we don't need to forget it.
The universities have been there since time in memorial to try to push that idea
forward through the generations,
and everyone needs to know that idea.
That's what gives you life,
not happiness.
Forget about that.
If it comes,
well,
great.
Except it dignity,
nobility,
character,
truth,
responsibility,
beauty.
Those are the things to aim for honor too.
I'd say honor.
Thank you very much and I hope when all this is done,
I hope you take a nice long,
big vacation cause I think you really deserve it.
Hello.
Okay,
Peterson first.
Thank you for coming.
And I'm so,
I'm Chinese.
My parents grew up in the cultural revolution of China,
so I took particular attention when you mentioned the multiple occasions
comparing what's happening in the West right now,
two miles,
China and I,
I agree and it's pretty obvious the connection between their radiology,
the identity politics and the oppression versus oppressed viewpoints.
But my question is mostly about how they're promoting the political agenda.
I mean,
I see that the political agenda,
the philosophy behind the political agenda are very similar,
but at the same time,
I see a shocking similarity in the way that they promoting that political
agenda.
Specifically backing back in the culture revolution.
Anyone who dare to say anything that it's not fully for the movement was
classified as Nq revolutionary.
Just as now who anyone who dare to say anything that goes remotely,
not fully aligned with whatever they want to promote is classified as hate
speech.
Although it has nothing to do with hate hating anybody.
So since the same thing is happening here and a Mao's China,
what would you say?
Well,
what,
what do you think is the connection between the philosophy and they're idiotic
oversimplifying and tyrannical way of him,
of trying to promoting it?
Well,
the first thing,
the first thing we should make clear is that there is such a thing as hate
speech,
right?
Like let's not be naive about this and you can use words to inflame and words
can be very dangerous tools.
People use them and hateful matters all the time.
That's not the issue.
That's obvious.
The issue is whether or not you should regulate out and even more importantly,
whether the state should regulate it.
And the reason that's an issue is because who's going to define it?
I'll tell you who's going to define hate speech.
It's the people who are doing that that are going to define hate speech.
And right now they're defining you sitting in here as hate speech.
I mean,
that's exactly what's going on while we sit here.
It's like who would be interested in defining the parameters of hate speech?
Here's the answer.
The people that you would least want to have adopt that responsibility and and
hate speech.
It's like,
let's say I was interviewed a while back and the journalist asked me,
well,
why should your right to a family Trump,
someone's right to be secure?
It's like,
okay,
well let's say I'm talking to one person and you might say,
well I don't have the right to offend them.
It's like,
all right,
what if I'm talking to 10 people?
Do I have the right to offend one of those people when I speak to the mortar,
if it's a thousand people,
what you're saying
[inaudible]
you can't,
you can't have a conversation about something serious without offense.
Like if I'm thinking about something serious,
like I often myself,
you know,
and I seriously mean that.
I really mean that.
So like if I'm laying out a set of hypotheses,
for example,
about a complex social,
a social problem,
I might lay out 20 hypothesis and maybe two of them.
I thank God,
I hope that's not true.
But like maybe it is true.
You know,
sometimes you discover things as a social scientist that you wish were true and
those are usually the things that you've discovered that are actually true,
right?
Cause they violate your assumptions.
So you can't even think if you're not willing to offend yourself.
That's what thinking does.
If you're ever talking about something wouldn't be serious if it didn't have the
possibility of frightening and offending people.
That's kind of how the,
that's kind of like the definition of seriousness.
It's like,
well,
we can only talk about things that no one ever gets upset about.
It's like,
well
then it's like you're trapped in an elevator for,
for the rest of infinity listening to nothing but Muzak you're,
that's an,
that's a kind of hell man.
If you're going to think,
and also if you're going to speak,
you're going to,
you're going to offend people.
You're going to go after their deepest presuppositions and end your own as well.
You're going to shatter them at times.
It's going to be brutal.
Absolutely brutal.
And you all know that because every single one of you has had a serious
conversation with someone that you love and the probability that that was an
easy conversation and that either of you escaped without offense and terror is
zero.
If you haven't had a conversation like that,
well,
well
you're not human,
right?
I mean right.
Cause everyone has conversations like that all the time except when they run
from them,
which is most of the time and no bloody wonder,
you know,
real conversations or there's nothing worse than a real conversation except the
war that you have if you don't have the conversation.
That's basically how it goes.
I just want to underline,
I just want to underline Jordan's first point,
which is really that it's a very dangerous thing.
Any legal rule that relies on some kind of reasonableness because reasonableness
lies in the eyes of the beholder.
I mean,
those out there
think that you guys are uttering hate speech.
They think that you guys should be the one who are arrested and just imagine if
they were the ones who had the reins of government power.
Just all very well hate speech as a reasonable idea.
But as soon as you give up the control about what that means,
you're liable to run into real trouble.
Yup.
Hello,
Mr. Rowe.
Well,
Mr. Peterson,
my name is Zachary Milligan.
Uh,
first off,
I'd just like to start to actually thank you for all the hardship and troubles
even dirt for standing up for our rights and being a part of this debate.
Um,
I come from a dairy farm and math need rural res conservatively.
And my question is in the face of when we have a social situation,
so divisive,
when you genuinely believe what you're doing is the right thing.
In this particular instance,
since you have experience with it,
what would you say?
Is there a more effective,
I don't want to say an easy way to reach out for them,
but what do you think's the best way to try and talk some sense into those folks
outside and the one on one setting?
So the first thing is is I don't necessarily the day I don't necessarily think
that what I'm doing is the right thing because you know,
you have to be careful when you make a claim like that.
But I can tell you one thing,
I'm not going to let anyone stand in the way of me trying to figure out what the
right thing is.
That's the thing.
And then I would say we're doing exactly what we should be doing right now in
this discussion.
It's,
it's just exactly right,
right?
I mean,
admittedly we have to talk over the noise,
but that's really not that big a catastrophe and everybody's in here is
comporting themselves in a reasonable manner.
And we're trying to struggle our way through the topics and we're,
we're asking questions and we're,
we're trying to have a genuine dialogue about them.
And that's what we've got.
We've got,
we've got three things.
We've got negotiation,
we've got slavery,
and we've got tyranny.
And those are your choices.
And so this is negotiation,
right?
That's public discourse.
And the reason that freedom of speech thought is obviously important.
And everyone can understand that.
You might say,
well,
you don't need to speak freely because you can think who's going to get inside
your head.
But the problem with that is that that's not it.
You can't think very well because there you are and your little world,
you know,
with all your biases and your ignorance,
you're wrong about so many things and you're going to learn it really painfully.
And,
and then maybe you can trot out some of the things you think erroneously and
ignorantly and other people will give you a tap on the side of the head instead
of running you over with a freight train,
right?
They'll give you a little tap on the side of the head and maybe you'll walk away
a little smarter.
And that's why freedom of speech is so important,
just because a lot of thinking,
especially about things that are beyond you for whatever reason,
have to take place publicly as we stumble around towards an adequate formulation
of the problems that beset us.
So I would say,
well in this book I wrote,
I have a rule.
It's,
I think it's rule eight which is tell the truth or at least don't lie.
I would say,
well,
that's another reasonable,
a reasonable way to start approaching the situation is it's not so easy to tell
the truth because like,
what do you know?
You know,
you can't come out and say,
well,
here's the truth,
but I know what one thing you can do,
which is when you know that what you're saying is a lie by your own standards,
you can not say it and you can have a consultation with yourself and you can try
to learn to say those things that make you strong.
Instead of saying those things that make you weak and you,
you contribute to the health of the public dialogue in an incalculable manner
that way.
And this is another issue that pertains to the dignity and importance of the
individual.
How you conduct yourself in your life is way more important than you think.
And,
and I mean I think that that's a daunting idea because you know,
let's say you're nihilistic and life is meaningless.
It's,
well,
what's the payoff for that?
I think,
well,
there's no payoff.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
there is,
you have no responsibility.
That's a pretty decent pay off.
I mean,
you have to pay the price of meaninglessness,
but it doesn't matter what you do.
Well,
we'll flip that over and said,
no,
sorry,
you're wrong.
Your life is meaningful.
It's way more meaningful than you think,
but you have to bear responsibility for your thoughts and your actions.
It's like you'll,
there'll be plenty of meaning and not well that if you understand that property,
that will,
that will cleave you to the depths of your soul and maybe you learn to speak
carefully at the act carefully and that will have a beneficial effect on
everyone around you if far more.
You're far more powerful in the place you stand in the place you sit and stand
than you think.
And I think everyone has an intimation of that.
And if you don't think that's true,
then try treating people around you as if it's not true.
Tried treating people that you know in your life as if they don't matter and
just see what kind of response you get.
People are not going to be happy with you,
not in any sense whatsoever.
You'll,
you'll ruin all your relationships.
You have to treat people as if they matter.
And maybe you have to treat them as if they matter because maybe they do.
And that goes for you too.
And so if you matter,
then you should act like you matter.
And that's a very,
that's a very daunting proposition.
That's for sure.
As a foot.
Go ahead.
As a,
it's just a footnote to that.
Let's just observe this in legal terms.
There are only two categories of actions,
voluntary and involuntary.
Don't let anybody tell you otherwise,
either you're choosing on your own and,
and handling the consequences or the government is telling you what to do.
Those are the only two possibilities.
Thank you,
sir.
At the back.
Go ahead.
Oh Duh.
Hello,
Dr. Peterson.
I would like to recall the part in your conversation in which you mentioned how
the radical left switched from the 1960s and seventies to being pro back when
they were a pro free speech and their recent,
um,
opposition to it.
I know,
I know that you often mentioned their obsession with power,
at least among them.
Yes.
At least among their more Marxists types.
I was one,
no,
I'm doing,
if perhaps they think that now,
now is the opportunity where they can consolidate their power and if they do so
successfully that it will become the mortality of our civilization for the next
thousand years.
Like Christianity was when Rome adopted.
Is that from what you've seen,
would you say that that's about it,
that that's close to the way there that's close to their strategy?
Well,
it's hard to exactly understand the strategy of an ideology,
you know,
because well all the people who were outside were,
were United in some sense under the umbrella of an idea and on an idea is a
living thing.
I mean it's embedded in living tissue and it's distributed in the fragmentary
manner across the mob,
let's say.
And each person in the mob always only only possess is a fragment of the
ideology because the full neo Marxist,
let's say the full neo Marxist postmodernist doctrine is quite complex.
And,
and,
but when you get the mob together,
then it acts under the dictate of the ideology.
And the question then is,
well,
what does the ideology want?
And I would say,
well,
it wants what it's formulators says it wants.
And D Derrida for example,
who's head trickster of the postmodernists regarded the western society as
fellow go centric.
Right?
And North that meant was male dominant,
male dominated.
That's the fellow fellas part.
And then logo centric.
While that refers to the word logos,
which means it's the root word of logic,
but there's also the,
it's also the,
the person of Christ,
essentially the logos.
And so the purpose of the postmodern critique was to demolish that wealth.
Fair enough.
My sense with people is,
especially if they're,
if they've written things down and thought them through that they're actually
aiming for what they say
they're aiming for.
Well,
if you,
if you buy the idea that the west is a male dominated tyranny,
essentially a patriarchal tyranny,
and that your moral duty is to tear it down,
well then that's what you're doing.
And then you might say,
well,
what's going to,
what is going to be erected on its ashes?
Well,
that's where things get complicated.
You know,
the first question might be,
are the people who wish to tear it down?
Builders,
or are they just destroyers?
And my strong sentiment is that they're primarily destroyers.
Now you might say,
well,
why do people wish to destroy?
Well,
it's because they're hurt by life and they're resentful
and resentful.
People become vengeful and vengeful.
People become dangerous.
And there's no shortage of motivation to make things worse.
Now that the school shooters make things worse,
people make things worse.
Now,
you know,
maybe lurking in the rhetoric is this appealed to an egalitarian utopia,
but we've tried utilitarian utopia is already,
we sacrificed 100 million people to [inaudible] Galitary in utopias,
and we have yet to produce one.
And so my sense is the corpse is stacked up high enough to constitute proof.
So
it's destruction mostly that motivates it as far as I can tell,
masquerading as compassion.
[inaudible]
thank you for that question.
Next place.
Dr. Peterson.
I said party.
Thank you both for being here today.
Um,
I'm a political scientist and what I've studied is totalitarian regimes.
I'm sorry,
I'm gonna move this a little bit.
To feel weird.
Totalitarian regimes.
I've studied,
I've tried to look at the Iranian revolution and the Islamic Republican,
Iran,
and I've argued how the Shia Islam that is teached in Islamic public is very
close to a totalitarian regime.
But now I live in a country where my ideas are considered controversial.
If you believe in God,
if you believe in family,
if you believe in having responsibility and traditional values,
I feel ostracized by the community here.
I came from UFC,
university of Calgary over there,
I didn't feel this way.
There was more welcoming.
Here I feel marginalized and I do feel alone.
And when I see this,
it disgusts me that here they can do this.
But I couldn't go to their events and do anything.
I'd have to shut up,
there'd be disciplinary committee for me.
But for them they can break windows to God knows how old this building is.
And it's okay for them to do that.
So my question to you is now being sheer,
experiencing this,
I'm starting to second guess that maybe the totalitarian Islamic regime that I
was so,
you know,
talking about and critical of back in Iran isn't so bad.
When I have a choice between having to be here and be depressed and be there and
at least have my ideas be okay with Lou regime.
So my argument is if this free speech and the arguments you're guys are making
here,
it doesn't work.
Would that not be the next step for people to go towards totalitarianism?
If dialogue fails and isn't force of arms the only thing left?
How can people compromise when they don't want to talk,
when they want to yell?
Thank you.
Okay.
I think you make it very good point.
I don't think we should fool ourselves.
This is about force and it is a,
it's almost a dare to suggest that that certain elements are not allowed to
enforce their view of the world and that speaking contrary to it,
isn't that a front to those values and they won't shut you down.
I mean that,
that that is what is at stake.
We,
we,
we are,
we are.
We are no longer really in a situation where this will all be resolved through
sort of gentle,
reasonable civil dialogue
that happens on the side,
but it's not real anymore.
It's not really where the fight is happening.
This is a,
an imposition of the force of the state and it is skewed.
It's skewed a certain way and we're getting to the point where a certain kind of
language,
a curtain,
certain kind of dialogue is,
is approved and all right and a certain kind.
It is not.
And that is the campaign that is going on that this is all part of.
And I have to say that,
that your presence here and,
and your endorsement of this kind of event is the kind of thing that has the
major pushback to that trend.
But the trend is continuing and is a very dangerous one.
And uh,
this is,
uh,
a difficult moment in the life of this country.
Would you,
would you say
Jordan Peele?
So,
so some,
some comments about,
about your career,
let's say.
Okay,
so you're a young mountain and you've got lots of years ahead of you.
So you know,
you want to prepare for the war and not for the battle,
right?
Okay.
Cause there's going to be many battles for you personally and perhaps
politically and all of that.
And so you want to make yourself as articulate and educated as you can and you
want to have patients.
I wouldn't say that there is no cause for despair,
you know?
I believe that the people who are attempting to radicalize our society and to
transform it into a battleground of identity politics are in a distinct
minority,
and I think that,
I think that there's no reason to assume that we can't push the devil back into
the,
into the bottle,
so to speak,
to push the genie back into the bottle,
and so don't despair.
Now from a personal perspective,
it's like we've got lots of things to learn and you've got lots of things to say
and to write and you're going to find now and then that you were imposed upon in
a manner that you don't find tolerable.
Right?
You think,
I can't live like this,
right?
It's going to distress you and well then,
then you've come across your moral conundrum,
right?
It's specific to you and then you have to,
that's when you have to grow up and think strategically.
It's like you decide are you willing to live under those conditions?
If you're not,
then you develop a strategy.
It's like,
okay,
I'm going to,
I'm going to fight this.
I'm going to fight it carefully,
intelligently,
thoughtfully on multiple fronts and I'm not going to back down.
You don't make that decision lightly.
You know most things you should let blow by you because there's not that much of
you and there's lots of things,
but now and then you'll find a stumbling block that you can't get over it
because it hurts you.
It damages your soul.
That's the right way to think about it.
Well then that's the time for you to put your education to use.
You know,
and you'll be able to do that.
I mean,
you don't want to underestimate the utility of of deep,
forthright speech.
I don't believe that anything can stand in its way.
You have the courage of your convictions,
but don't give way to despair.
Like this battle is by no means over.
Nope.
I know meat and it isn't even obvious that the bad guys are winning,
so to speak.
You know?
I mean,
here we are,
we're having this talk.
The university came out forthrightly in favor of free speech.
Hooray for that
[inaudible]
no one and so far all the questions today have been thoughtful and intelligent.
You seem like informed people.
It's like don't underestimate your strength.
And so,
and McMaster just published a set of guidelines governing this sort of behavior
so that will no longer be acceptable to disrupt perfectly reasonable proceedings
on university campuses.
And so that,
so the discussions like this can continue properly.
I mean there's definitely a place for give and take and for informed opposition,
let's say.
But there's a difference between informed opposition and child childish grand
standing.
And I think people know the difference between that.
So don't,
don't be desperate about it by not pick your battles.
A little courage goes a long way,
right?
Because other people see it and there's that,
there is,
I think a silent majority out there that is silent and is scared.
But if they see courage from somebody,
they responded to it.
Well,
I think you described lawyers in a way that appealed to me once.
He said,
I think,
I know that's rare,
but
you said lawyers,
I think these are the words you said.
Lawyers are
difficult and emotionally stable.
And it was the combination of those two things,
the willingness to be difficult,
but not to be emotional about it.
So don't,
don't,
where'd your emotions to the fight?
Take a step back,
engage in it,
see what you think.
Be Courageous,
but don't get wrapped up in it.
Don't be emotional about it,
but you know,
retain your strength for the long haul.
Yup.
Well,
you know,
one of the things I've learned strategically,
and this is really we're thinking about too,
is that when you're engaged in a public dispute like this,
it's not obvious when things are going your way.
You know,
you think,
well,
this protest is not such a good thing.
It's like,
I wouldn't be so sure about that.
You know what's happened to me in the last 18 months is that virtually every
time that I been attacked and some of the attacks have been quite well,
I wouldn't say brutal because we haven't got to that thank God,
but they've certainly been,
um,
they've taken me aback.
You know,
it's not,
it's not a straight forward thing to be in a hall with.
And this happened at McMaster with a hundred people yelling at you and Larry
near horns and all of that.
But that wasn't a bad thing as it turned out because it was filmed and it was
put on Youtube and it was terrible for the people who protested,
you know,
it wasn't good.
And so you got to detach yourself to,
you know,
if,
if you say what you think and you're careful about it,
it's going to have some short term effects and it's going to have some medium
term with exit.
It's going to have some long term effects.
And one of the things that you need to do,
I would say,
and this is an element of courage,
is you have to have faith that the medium to longterm consequences of you saying
what you have to say as clearly as possible.
It's going to be positive and you have to act on that supposition.
You don't know,
right?
You can't know that that's the existential leap of faith is you.
You can't know,
but you act anyway.
And my experience has been that you don't want to,
you don't want to make judgment too quickly because it's not always clear when
things are going your way.
So when you know,
you might stand up into class and say something that people react negatively to
eat and you might get pilloried for that by some people,
but you never know who you're touching in the crowd and you don't know how
that's going to unfold across time.
Now you who that might be a defining moment in someone else's life to watch you
stand up and say what you have to say.
So don't underestimate the power of truth and courage really.
So
[inaudible]
honestly,
they should be thankful.
And how civil and how peaceful you guys are.
They should be thankful.
They shouldn't be angry.
I regret to say we probably have time for probably
just a couple more questions.
So let's
go to the back.
Hi.
Um,
so my question is directed at Dr. Peterson.
I've been watching your lectures online for a while and um,
you talk a lot,
come a little closer to the bank,
you speak a lot about that's better.
You speak a lot about character arc types and a narrative and the importance of
the young Ian idea of the
personal narrative.
Um,
I
am having trouble formulating this into a question,
but I guess with the idea of art types in mind,
um,
are you familiar with,
uh,
been neue Mandel broads idea of fractal patterns?
Um,
and if so,
what do you think and if,
is there a connection there maybe to be found?
Well,
there seems to be a metaphorical connection in that the great is,
is reproduced in the small,
and that's certainly an idea that permeates,
let's say religious and theological speculation.
You know,
there's an idea that here's an idea that it's like the idea of the genie,
which is the re same root word as genius,
the genius,
something of unimaginable power that's constrained in a very small space.
And that's kind of what a person is like.
You know,
we have this affinity,
we have this connection to the infinite,
we have this connection to the divine,
but we're,
but it's constrained within within our frames,
right?
And we have to act out that the divine narrative in the confines of our own
life.
And so there is this overarching reality,
which is something like the fo the forthright confrontation with the catastrophe
of life,
right?
And,
but that has to be made personal,
you know,
so that,
that's one of yoga,
I would say,
deepest ideas,
is that the archetipal has to be made personally in your own life.
And so you take the generic pattern and you personalize it,
and then the infinite and the finite meat.
And that's the perfect combination.
And there's something about that that's,
well,
honorably profound I would say.
And,
and,
and as true as anything can be,
and I think people know this at the very deep level because you do know when
you're struggling to go to sleep at night and your conscience is bothering you
and you think through the things that you did in the day,
in the week,
you'll take solace in the things that you did that were noble and true and you,
and you can,
you can breathe a sigh of relief that you're not completely corrupt and lost and
then you can sleep.
It's like everyone knows this.
Well,
we need to know it consciously,
right?
And that's part of the process,
making the archetypal personal and that,
that's part of what the religious process is supposed to be about,
is to outline the,
the archetipal pattern and then to say,
look,
you have to meditate on this.
And you have to figure out how to make it true in the confines of your own life.
And that gives,
see the reason that works I think is because there's no doubt that your life is
tragic and there's no doubt that you have a bilevel and element and that you'll
be touched by betrayal and all those terrible things.
But there's a nobility about youtue and that nobility might be sufficient to
transcend your limitations.
And I would say that your life is a struggle to determine if that might be the
case.
And that's the act of faith.
And I also do believe I was asked today by South African journalist if I'm the
ultimate pessimist or the ultimate optimist,
no one.
I would say in some ways I am the ultimate pessimist.
I know I think as much as I can tolerate how terrible life can be,
but I do believe that the human spirit can overcome that catastrophe and can
rise out of it.
And I think the universities are that that idea expressed in stone and tradition
and it's a great idea.
Everyone needs the idea,
especially people who are young,
you know your life is,
you know that your life is going to be difficult.
It's like no one can say,
well,
it's going to be easy.
But you might say,
well,
do you want it to be easy?
What's in it for you?
If it's easy,
well,
no,
you want it to be difficult and worthwhile and you want to be the sort of person
that can manage that and that's what you should be.
That's what you should be encouraged to be at university.
And,
and that's what the universities are for.
So,
well that's the archetipal and the personal,
I would say.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
this will,
uh,
this will have to be our last question.
Go ahead,
sir.
In recent time,
uh,
I would probably identify the most recent us election is the turning point for
this.
And that's,
I've seen that as an American citizen,
this is my first time living in Canada.
Um,
I've noticed that public discourse has taken to elevate fascism as the ultimate
evil and maybe rightfully so.
You know,
there were many horrific things commit by fascist states in the 20th century and
you see people,
you know,
like Facebook cover photos like bash the past,
you see,
you let stickers on laptops,
this machine kills fascists.
It is,
you know,
there's this big backlash against fascism and the horrors that it caused,
but in spite of that,
you don't see the same reaction to the horrors and the genocide that were caused
by socialist and Communist states in the 20th century.
Do not.
You see people who virtue signal endlessly about how horrible the Holocaust was,
about how awful these things were.
And then just hand away the famine,
genocide of the Ukraine,
the great leap forward.
They think these things are inconsequential or even necessary sacrifices for the
rise of the greater good of socialism or communism.
And I personally find that morally reprehensible and I can't understand where
that,
where that comes in,
how you can stand there and be so opposed to this genocide.
What say that this genocide is somehow just,
oh,
it's not a problem.
And why do you think that?
How do you think that disconnect happens?
How do you think people can convince themselves of that and why do you think
that happens?
It's a great question.
Um,
you know,
I have,
my house is covered with,
with art from the Soviet era and I have a road of reasons for that.
Part of it is to remind me of what happened.
Part of it is to watch the struggle between the art and the propaganda on the
canvasses sort of in real time.
You know,
I'm very interested in that,
but I would never decorate my house with Nazi Regalia,
you know,
and,
and you think,
well,
why is that exactly?
It's not like,
I don't know that that what happened in the communist regimes was utterly
reprehensible.
Why is it,
and perhaps it's not acceptable to have,
you know,
socialist realist paintings in your house,
but it's certainly more acceptable or it seems that way than to have paintings
from the Nazi era,
let's say.
So then you think,
well,
why is that exactly?
And I think,
you know,
back in 1918 at the door and the Russian revolution,
when Europe was inflamed and in ruins and the monarchical societies were
collapsing and the industrial revolution was in full force and there were
terrible,
there was terrible poverty and terrible inequality.
The dream of Universal Brotherhood was a compelling dream.
The dream of egalitarianism and,
and,
and maybe,
maybe who knows how much of it was motivated by genuine benevolence.
Some Middle East.
It's very difficult to see that the Nazi,
the Nazi phenomenon was ever generated by any genuine benevolence.
That's very difficult to,
to make a case for.
Um,
so maybe you can forgive the,
the socialists,
the communists utopians a hundred years ago because they didn't know what they
were getting in for.
People had warned them.
Dostoevsky warn the Nitro,
warn them.
But,
but still,
and then the other thing too is the problem of inequality.
It's like the problem of inequality is a real problem and it doesn't go away.
Like it's very difficult when you walk down Bluer Street for example,
in Toronto and you see homeless people,
alcoholics and drug addicts who are struggling.
And the mentally ill who are on the street and they're in their little domain of
hell.
It's,
it's really difficult for that to not tear at your heart strings and say,
well,
isn't the world and unjust place or an unfair place,
which it is.
And so you can see the never ending wellsprings of motivation to support the
oppressed.
And I think the fact that the Communists,
the communist dogma,
at least had that as part of its initiating ethos is partly what seems to make
it forgivable.
I also think it's
easier for people to identify why fascism is wrong.
We can say,
look,
racial superiority,
nope.
Okay.
It's pretty simple,
right?
It's three words.
You can really get it,
but,
but equality of outcome,
it's like that's really wrong.
It's really wrong.
But it's not so obvious why,
right?
It isn't,
you can't just say equality of outcome,
know and have everyone clap because it isn't as well.
And that's the thing.
It's really difficult to,
it's difficult to isolate the pathological elements in radical left wing thought
because they're not self evidently pathological.
Like there's this old cliche,
um,
from each,
according to his ability to each according to his need.
It's like,
yeah,
that sounds pretty good.
We have needs.
It's like,
let's have them fulfilled and well you have an ability,
well like manifested.
It's like,
well it doesn't work in practice in in fact it's murderous in practice and it's
a great catastrophe in some sense that it's murderous in practice.
So I just think it's maybe part of it is,
is just a hell of a lot harder to learn why it's wrong.
That combined with,
you know,
the genuine outpouring of compassion for the oppressed and [inaudible] which is
like who's for poverty?
No one.
Right.
And,
and inequality is a painful reality.
It's painful for everyone.
You know,
even people who are self righteous about their,
their status,
let's say,
in,
in the depths of their soul.
The struggling of the fact of the struggling still rips at them.
And so
it's a more difficult lesson for us to learn.
So yeah.
[inaudible]
do those people lined up at the mics?
I sorry for leaving you hanging.
I'm sure we could go on all night if we had the time.
Um,
but we must call this to a close.
I would like to
salute you
for your patients and your dedication in the face of the noise from outside.
Very nicely done.
Hold on.
[inaudible]
as you,
uh,
as you no doubt are aware,
Professor Peterson has written an international best seller.
It's called 12 rules for life.
There are some presale in the hall now before you go,
let me just say this,
you have participated in what I would consider to be an important step in the
life of this university and for that we should thank you.
So thank you for coming and thank you for your support.
[inaudible]
professor Peterson,
uh,
maybe the most important intellectual,
a voice in this country today and I would like to thank him very much for
coming.
[inaudible]
great night.
Be Safe.
I just have,
sorry,
I just have one small thing to say.
Hold on.
I would,
I would very much like to stay and talk with a bunch of you and I generally do
that,
but I can't do it today because I have to go back to Toronto when I'm going to
Australia tomorrow.
So I don't,
I can't do that even though I would like to,
so I have to run off and then I have to drive back to Toronto and,
but despite that,
thank you very much for coming and for being patient and all of that.
Yup.
Okay.
Why is
it
great
shame on Queens?
No freedom for hate speech.
He says he really,
really chosen where I'm at with him.
I've been looking at his voice that we're looking at the protest points.
I'm not really sure.
Um,
I just think it's interesting that he's drawing the sort of crowd and that,
you know,
what's happening here is happening.
I think that really says something about participation at Queens.
We're here to protest a Jordan Peterson Dean.
You give him the platform at Cuny University.
Um,
Jordan Peterson,
aside from not knowing what he's talking about,
these are a lot,
uh,
Pearson pension type.
It's not a discussion about which topics do you like on pizza.
It's a discussion about which people should be considered funeral,
which you lose your respect.
And that's not a debate that can happen anywhere.
I love that they are here.
How did this,
this course he does.
They don't agree with what he has to say so they're showing it.
But uh,
I have seen a lot of people call to cancel.
They are showing the Daniel Walsh should be ashamed of himself for allowing this
to happen.
And that I just think is wrong.
I don't know if it seems like we have a lot of very angry people in here because
someone's expressing an idea different than their own and here at a university,
I kind of thought that was.
Thank you.
Would you like one more Pepsi Cola?
I'm good.
Okay.
Same.
Those groups
sell
fresh
eggs.
It takes bravery to say of that.
It was only stuff to what guys?
Yeah,
they broke the fucking window.
I'll run in there.
Jesus Christ.
Crazy,
crazy.